after Warner Brothers Unleashed two and
a half minutes of glorious Joker footage
in early April 2019 and picked apart
each scene analyzed every frame and
watch the whole thing multiple times in
efforts to catch every subtle reference
to pop culture and to Batman comics past
people picked up on the wink of the King
of Comedy with Robert De Niro's casting
as a talk-show host the parallel to a
classic Joker costume in the teasers
final shots and the allusion to another
famous pale-faced icon Charlie Chaplin
with the banners hanging outside Wayne
Hall what most may not have noticed the
first second or tenth time around is
that the Joker teaser also includes what
could be an Easter Egg for the Riddler
a longtime foe of Batman at the 57th
second mark of the footage during the
scene in which Joaquin Phoenix's Arthur
Fleck is standing in an elevator at
Arkham State Hospital viewers can spot a
green-ink graffiti on the wall behind
him though the tag doesn't appear to
hold any deeper meaning that punctuation
mark is intriguing as it's the insignia
of Edward nygma better known as the
Riddler fans are beginning to think that
this could mean the Riddler is hiding in
the shadows of director Todd Phillips
his version of Gotham City one of the
famous baddies in the Dark Knight's
rogues gallery the Riddler has spent a
ton of time locked up in Arkham Asylum
seemingly reimagined for Joker as Arkham
State Hospital which apparently counts
Arthur Fleck as a regular visitor but
this sneaky green question mark appears
not just anywhere but on an elevator in
Gotham's home for the criminally insane
at some credence to the idea that the
graffiti could be a legitimate Riddler
Easter egg and could pretend an
appearance by nygma himself that would
unquestionably be an awesome surprise
was that over-the-top I can never tell
it wouldn't be the only clever nod to
Batman comics featured in the new Joker
footage all the only one included in
connection with Arkham state hospital
just after the camera sweeps across
Gotham City in the first few seconds the
teaser shows Phoenix is Arthur sitting
opposite a social worker played by
Sharon Washington her nametag reveals
that her name is Deborah Kane if that
surname sounds familiar it's because
it's the same one as Batman co-creator
Bob Kane and as Batman's cousin Kay Kane
otherwise known as Batwoman
there are a few other names revealed in
the trailer that could be meaningful or
not for exam
there's a street sign that reads Jerome
Avenue the DC television series Gotham
features a character named Jerome
Valeska who is a precursor to the Joker
much like Arthur Fleck is a man who
eventually becomes a clownish criminal
and the upcoming Joker movie then
there's the existence of Holmes pharmacy
which appears 10 seconds into the teaser
when Arthur is walking down the street
Batman is known as the world's greatest
detective and so is Sherlock Holmes
with a little mental gymnastics one
could deduce that Joker including a
pharmacy seemingly named for the other
best fictional crime solver on the
planets might teaser Arthur's life
connects with Bruce Wayne's or maybe the
production designer just liked the look
of the name Holmes on the sign taking
all this into accounts it's clear how
easy it is to make something out of what
very well could be nothing the green
question mark inked on the Arkham State
Hospital elevator is certainly
interesting but whether it's actually a
Riddler Easter Egg is anyone's guess
could it be sure might it just be Todd
Phillips wanting to tip his hat to the
comics while keeping Joker its own
outside of the DC EU thing absolutely
the beauty of this uncertainty is that
fans now have yet another reason to look
forward to Joker beyond what looks to be
a bang-up performance by Phoenix when
the film opens in theaters on October
4th all questions shall be answered and
or potential Easter eggs will hopefully
be followed upon check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
loop of videos but your favorite DC
characters are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]